we're in a pin just north west of
uh the capital kyiv and it's a highly
significant place i'll tell you where we
are at the uh civic center a lot of
you can see the bullets in the walls
here an intense fight going on here and
if we go inside um it's a cultural
center as well as a
as a civic administration building but
it's uh
i mean it's been substantially
damaged i've destroyed really with shell
fire and
rocket fire and the significance of this
is that the ukrainian forces held out
here
this is where they blocked the russian
advance on kiev
just at the beginning of the war and
and they stopped the russian advance and
who knows what would have happened had
the russians been able to get through
here but the fighters here and the
residents here became known as the hero
defenders the city is known now as the
hero city of
um ukraine you can see the damage here
and that's the cost of the resistance
that they put up
and uh
as i say a very significant battle here
in urpin and uh one that certainly the
people in the capital are very grateful
for now the russians
moved away their forces from the capital
and are now concentrating as we were
just hearing uh their forces in the
southeast
um in the donbass it is quite possible
though that if things if this war drags
on then president putin could
concentrate again
on
um keeve and then this place
could have
another role it would have to be
a pretty a place of stout defense once
again so this war may not be over for
this um town of
a pin